à partir de lundi il faudra montrer
patte blanche pour pouvoir entrer dans
les restaurants de la capitale
en effet au vu de la dégradation de la
situation sanitaire les autorités
municipales ont décidé de frapper fort à
partir du 28 juin 2021
seuls ceux qui sont protégés contre le
coc vide 19 pourront fréquenter les
restaurants ceux qui se sont fait
vacciner ceux qui ont été infectés par
le cos vide 19 au cours des six derniers
mois
ceux qui ont un test pc un négatif de -2
3 jours concrètement il faudra à l'aide
de son téléphone montré un qr code comme
celui ci comme quoi on est bien
immunisés cette mesure inspirée de ce
qui a déjà été fait en israël lors de
son déconfinement a été adopté en
conséquence de la flambée de kobe de
constater ces dernières semaines en
grande partie à cause du variant delta
les restaurateurs pour leur part cherche
avant tout à éviter le scénario de
l'année dernière lorsqu'il avait dû
fermer leur établissement pendant de
longs mois
donc il s'adapte en général nous faisons
attention à la santé des gens ici pour
le moment toutes les mesures prises ne
suffisent pas alors d'autres mesures
sont nécessaires à la vaccination est
l'une de ces mesures c'est tout c'est
très simple nous nous plaidons pour la
santé de la nation la clientèle elle est
plus partagé vous savez nos invités
réagissent différemment tout comme elles
réagissent différemment aux vaccins ils
réagissent à 2t les expériences tout
comme ils réagissent aux vaccins les
gens sont différents
je sais que c'est pas bien
premièrement des personnes vaccinées ont
vacciné sont séparées les unes des
autres ce qui me semble-t-il entraînera
des protestations à l'avenir je n'aime
pas ça moi personnellement je suis
contre la vaccination
je ne prévois pas de me faire vacciner
je n'ai pas l'intention de le faire bien
que je sois propriétaire d'une
entreprise
quant à mes employés je ne vais pas les
appeler à le faire non plus je le répète
encore une fois j'ai eu une approche
prudente envers cette question
j'aimerais avoir plus d'information à
propos de cela avant de prendre cette
décision de me faire vacciner
il faut dire que la situation de ces
derniers jours de ces dernières semaines
est très préoccupante
malheureusement la situation est
complexe
aujourd'hui nous sommes presque au pic
de l'incidence si on compare avec les
périodes précédentes
mais ce qui est encourageant c'est que
les gens ont tout de même commencé à se
faire vacciner plus activement je ne
sais pas si vous le constatez selon
l'affluence à vos points de vaccination
hier un nombre record de vaccination a
été enregistré environ 60 milles
récemment on était tombé jusqu'à environ
6000 par jour le nombre d'inscriptions à
la vaccination est presque multiplié par
dix c'est encourageant
cela signifie que dans les mois à venir
les moscovites peuvent obtenir une
protection fiable contre la pandémie et
stabiliser la situation revenir à une
vie normale
résultat les autorités décident
d'adopter des mesures contraignantes en
espérant que celles-ci portent leurs
fruits